so um what i think is really interesting
is think of a date like uh uh like a job
interview right um and think of a job
interview like a date right so um if you
went on a on a first date with someone
and they sat down they said you know um
i'm extremely rich
um i've made lots of money i do lots of
cool things i met a lot of famous people
um i go on tv all the time which is good
because i'm really good looking
uh yeah yeah
would you want to go on a second date
with them right not very appealing it's
also not very appealing when we sit down
for a job interview and just tell people
how great we are and all the things that
we've done it's the same kind of thing
now imagine if you knew your why
and you're making conversation with
someone
and they say so you know where you from
what you know tell me a little bit about
you
and you say you know
i love what i do i love my life i love
my job you can say i i
i wake up every day to inspire people to
do the things that inspire them and for
me the challenge is finding all the
different ways that i could do it um and
i've been really really
grateful for the path that it's taken me
and i've i've made some money and i've
get to go on tv which is funny because
i'm really good looking and you can see
how all the same jokes and all the same
things now have a context and that's
what why does it provides context it
also helps you connect with somebody
that when somebody's telling you about
themselves and you ask some questions
and you get to know them a little bit
you realize that maybe their values are
completely different than yours so why
gives you clarity and confidence in who
you are and what you need around you um
but it also helps you present yourself
in a way that's way more authentic now
there's a there's a there's a rub to the
why that i don't talk about that often
because you really have to get good at
giving your why before you can deal with
this but the the difficult part about
knowing your why is the thing that you
give to the world the value you give and
offer to other people is also the thing
you need the most
so it's one so one of the ways to to
to
understand the people in our lives
partners and mates is can they actually
give us the thing that we give to other
people
you